Inside every cell of your body, billions
of tiny machines are hard at work.
They carry oxygen in your blood,
let your eyesdetect light
and even make your muscles move.
These machines are proteins
and they underpinevery
biological process in every living thing.
Each protein has an intricate 3d shape that
defines what it does and how it works.
We know ofover 200 million proteins
and counting.
But we onlyknow the exact 3D shapes
of a fraction of these.
Unravel a protein and you'll see it's like a
string of beads
made up of 20 different types
of amino acids.
Interactions between these aminoacids
make the protein fold
as it finds its shapeout of almost
limitless possibilities.
For decades a community of
scientists have been working on a
way to figure out a protein shape
just from itsstring of amino acids.
This is a major challengein our
understanding of biology
So, we created anAI system
to solve this problem...
called AlphaFold.
It's trained on the sequences and structures of
about a hundred thousand proteins
painstakinglymapped out
by scientists around the world.
Today it can accurately predict
a protein's shape...
just from its sequence of amino acids.
AlphaFold's predictions could
enable progress inall sorts of areas.
Imagine a future wherewe
can understand diseases more quickly...
and develop drugs to fight them.
Or one wherewe could use enzymes
to break down plasticwaste...
or even to capture carbon from the
atmosphere.
All with the help of proteins.
There's a lot more work to be done
but unlockingthe shapes
of these building blocks
could help scientists
better understand the naturalworld...
and perhaps expand our
knowledge of life itself.